[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAIGE BAILEY: Hi.
I'm Paige, and I'm a Developer
Advocate for TensorFlow.
Machine learning techniques like
Convolutional Neural Networks,
also called CNNs, and Generative
Adversarial Networks, or GANs,
have shown great promise in a
diverse range of applications--
everything from
image classification
to scene reconstruction
to speech recognition.
To efficiently
train these models
on massive amounts of data,
machine learning engineers
often need to use specialized
hardware, such as Graphics
Processing Units, GPUs, or
Tensor Processing Units, TPUs.
GPUs and TPUs are
used as accelerators
for the portions of the
model that can be broken up
into parallelizable operations.
Think of these chips as
very specialized tools
that can do one particular task
extremely well and extremely
quickly.
When using this
specialized hardware,
tasks that used to take days
or even weeks to complete now
can only take minutes.
The good news is that you can
develop deep learning models
on Google Colab using
GPU and TPU at no cost.
Let's dive into a
notebook and check it out.
To change your runtime in
Google Colab, all you have to do
is select Runtime, Change
Runtime Type, and then
opt for None, GPU, or TPU.
For this selection, we'll go
with GPU, and we'll hit Save.
Let's install TensorFlow
2.0 with GPU support.
We can confirm that TensorFlow
can see the GPU by running
device name=tf.test.gpu
device name.
Once the command has run,
we can see that the device
is located at the 0 slot.
To observe the TensorFlow
speed-up on GPU
relative to CPU, let's use
this basic keras model.
We hit Run, and
we find that mnest
is able to train to completion
in around 43 seconds.
With CPU, it would
take mnest 69 seconds
to achieve the same accuracy.
So you received almost a
third of a boost of speed.
If you're interested
in obtaining
additional information
about hardware,
you can run these two commands
from any Colab notebook.
This will tell you
everything that you
need to know about
CPU, RAM, and GPU.
For TPUs, let's try a bit more
interesting of an example.
We'll change the runtime
type again, select TPU,
and hit Save.
Here, we're
predicting Shakespeare
with TPUs and keras.
In this Colab notebook, we'll
build a two-layer forward LSTM
model, and we'll convert a keras
model to its equivalent TPU
version, using the standard
keras methods Fit, Predict,
and Evaluate.
As we scroll down, we can see
that we're downloading data,
we're building a data
generator with TF logging,
we're checking to see the
size of the array coming in
from Project Gutenberg, and
we're building our model.
This model will take quite a
while to train, but remember,
you're training against
every single aspect
of Shakespeare's corpus.
After we've cycled
through 10 [? epochs ?]
and we have pretty
good accuracy,
we can start making
predictions with our model.
Let's take a look at what
a neural network thinks
might be a Shakespearean play.
So it's obviously not perfect.
AI can't be the Bard yet.
But this does look like
a traditional script.
And you can see that if you
start adding layers, adding
nodes, and even adding clusters
of TPUs as opposed to just one,
you'll improve your
accuracy even more
and start generating
Shakespeare-like plays
all on your own.
You just learned how to
accelerate your machine
learning projects with GPUs
and TPUs in Google Colab.
In the next video, I'll
walk you through how
to upgrade your
existing TensorFlow
code to TensorFlow 2.0.
So subscribe to the
TensorFlow YouTube channel
and be notified when
that video lands.
In the meantime, keep building
cool projects with TensorFlow,
and make sure to share them
on Twitter with the hashtag
#PoweredbyTF.
We're looking forward to
seeing what you create.
And I'll see you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]